[Music]
did you watch sex in the city the reboot
no another show that that they brought
back for no reason or i don't know maybe
for i i never watched the original me
either but they they brought back the
show in episode one this like beloved
character i guess i don't really know
much about it but people were really
really sad about the fact that he oh
spoiler alert by the way fast forward a
little bit you don't i don't know how
much crossover we have with sex in the
city
that's true because it's like women it's
like millennial
women
yeah right or older actually i don't
know
you think so it's like mid-30s women
that watch that show yeah cause like
when millennials are older i don't know
that's probably whatever spoiler alert
yeah that's fine but anyways he dies
this guy this guy
mr big dies
and now i so i asked how does he die
on a peloton
yes he's riding a peloton he has a heart
attack
and dies
john
did peloton agree to this no i don't
think so because their stock dropped
like what 10 or more than 10 it was 11
but they did agree they also they did
agree they also casted one of their
instructors to be in the episode but hbo
didn't tell them the script context no
way that's hilarious yeah let's do a bit
where the target audience that we market
these bikes to we're gonna kill someone
on that bike yeah yeah they didn't they
didn't know he was gonna die i guess
they just agreed to give them the bike
for the show
so he dies on the peloton
and the stock drops 10
and everyone's really distraught about
the fact that this guy died 10 that's
how much mr big is worth ten percent of
peloton yeah which is how much money
what's their market cap like seven
dollars
it's been going down a lot since
um the pandemic has kind of been
shaping up so i don't know exactly what
it's at now let me look in my portfolio
i have 12.9 billion
i'm sorry 12.9 billion yeah so they're
fine that so that means that they
dropped like
they lost like a billion dollars in
value that's what he's worth a billion a
billion dollars
yeah their stocks were getting [ __ ]
hammered holy [ __ ] well it's because
like father treadmills are killing
babies and [ __ ] like that and they've
been having trouble for a while but yeah
it's true yeah they got the kid killer
treadmill but this is the one thing they
did right
was they then in an emergency
situation casted mr big for an ad and
shot this ad in like 12 hours
to new beginnings
to new beginnings
you look great i feel great
should we take another ride
life's too short not to
[Music]
just like that the world was reminded
that regular cycling stimulates and
improves your heart lungs and
circulation reducing your risk of
cardiovascular diseases cycling
strengthens your heart muscles lowers
resting pulse and reduces blood fat
levels he's alive
nice ryan
good job and you know the craziest thing
is
that girl is the peloton instructor
whose wife piss on the guy's face
yeah
pee pee
that's her pee pee
and what else is crazy is that remember
last year at this exact same time ryan
reynolds made that ad for his gin
company using i casted the girl from the
peloton ad i think peloton reached out
to his marketing company yeah to make
this because it has the exact same tone
definitely isn't that [ __ ] wild ryan
is [ __ ] kidding
kills it man
i think that's just a cool kind of full
circle moment capitalism
right so sigma billion dollar
organizations just collaborate with just
come together yeah and make something
good for the human race yeah i love a
good commercial dude
what in the [ __ ] okay so this is i asked
i asked i guess ryan to be like why or
kyle to do research into why people love
mr big because so many people were
talking about this and so this comes
from ryan's fiance's friend you're gonna
do a very misogynistic presentation of
this how should i do it let me just talk
like a
just do the atypical white girl voice
candles let's bring the lights low
let's get dramatic in this man
yeah i can i can jump in and you can
jump in and we can just tag team it
ready
okay this is the average
sex in the city viewer
okay
why do we love big
it's complex it's important to know that
both carrie and big are very flawed
characters
they are frustrating for the audience
and they both flip between being the
protagonist and the antagonist in the
series but i love big because carrie and
he grew up together and it was a mess
they were each other's vices for sure
and they hurt others and each other and
themselves along the way as they fumbled
through their relationship their
relationship took many forms and despite
it being so complicated it was so
exciting when they ended up together i
think it was exciting because it felt
like they had really struggled
throughout their journey it was a fairy
tale and it took them a long time to see
the light also he built her a really
nice closet
oh
yeah woodworker okay now i get it no so
it's basically what you know happened in
the formula one race they just hit a
switch they're like i just
just take him out yeah let's get rid of
him yeah
get his ass out of there
oh that's whack so episode one they just
kill a very major character yep that's
really smart why the [ __ ] would they do
that cause they're rebooting a show they
need some [ __ ] to happen yeah also maybe
it's just kind of like a
they're like let's just remind people
life
kind of [ __ ] up yeah
you know oh speaking of [ __ ] up i feel
like
you know
so last week i brought up
the medieval movie
you know uh yeah last day yeah i've
almost watched that like four times yeah
and i had kyle take out
some of my jokes because i thought they
were a little bit insensitive
because when i
you know and i i'll say this i was i was
making jokes about how i hadn't watched
the woman chapter of the movie yet you
know and i was like it's probably gonna
be really long and boring
i ate those words
why yes dude why
it is the most horrific
like the movie does this really
interesting job of presenting a scenario
from three different perspectives
and
naturally adam driver's character
presents the scenarios really like it's
like a fantasy and it's very sort of you
know it's like
two people frolicking
you know
in their love
their like you know their secret love
for each other and then it gets to her
telling of it and it is [ __ ] violent
like oh bad it really sets up the later
half of the film but yeah i i watched it
and i just
messed this kyle on slack immediately
i'm like yeah those jokes gotta go
that
no those can't hang it i got to watch
that
yeah is it good oh bro
it's it's long but
yeah the last duel is
you know i love a good duel
no hey hey i love being in a good duel
first of all you know i like dual
citizenship so do i yeah uh they wear
the same
colors that we wore no way
maybe that's what inspired the movie
yeah
they saw cody
yeah yeah they watched the moment house
show yeah they're like we got to do a
film yeah
he called up
ben affleck yeah
what do you think of this well
unfortunately i'm wearing the wrong
guy's color
like if you look back at our footage
yeah
so he's guilty
um don't tell me i want to watch it i
want to watch it